thank you very much for the introduction
um yeah i'm happy to present to you
today
our first experience that we have with
the new intolerant genexos
system and especially with the focus on
the workflow and how it compares
to our current workflow that we're
employing in our molecular pathology
laboratory
so this is my disclaimer
so before getting into the genexous
system i just very quickly
want to give you an overview of a
typical workflow
for next generation sequencing how it is
employed in many molecular pathology
laboratories
so basically we have five main steps we
start from
our tissue on the left so in this case
uh
it's it's a formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue block but of
course we can
also have different sample types such as
cytological smears or blood samples from
which we
then separate the plasma and extract the
cell-free dna
depending on the sample type we choose
the appropriate
nucleic acid extraction kit from which
we then obtain
dna and rna once we have the nucleic
acids
we proceed with library preparation
with which we enrich the cancer relevant
genes
that are specific for specific tumor
types
for example we can have very small
panels for colon and lung for example in
our laboratory but we also have
larger panels for when we have cancers
of unknown primary
and you will actually hear more about
these larger panels
and the purpose of these in one of the
next talks today
so once we have our sequencing library
we proceed with
sequencing in our laboratory we do this
using the iron torrent system currently
we use the
s5 system and then once we have the
sequencing data
we use the iron reporter system to
perform the variant calling
and and identify the variants
that we will eventually put on our
report
so all in all currently this entire
workflow takes us
around in an ideal case around four to
five days to get from
sample to final report
of course there are more tricky samples
that sometimes require
optimizations in the workflow so it's
possible that
that the the workflow may actually take
even
a few days longer now considering that
it is quite critical especially for
newly diagnosed advanced non-small cell
lung cancer to get a molecular profile
as quickly as possible
of course we are very interested in
trying to get this
turnaround time as short as possible and
optimize it
even further in fact this is why we were
very happy to hear
about the new genexo system which
promises
uh turnaround time as short as one day
to get from sample to report so of
course we really wanted to try this
and luckily we had the opportunity over
the last six months or so to
uh to extensively test this system
and uh we can he confirmed that that
we can get ngs results uh
in as short as one day in addition the
full
the workflow from library prep to data
analysis is now fully automated so it
requires
very little hands-on uh very little
technical knowledge
about it um plus it is more flexible in
terms of throughput as our current
system with the iron chef
and the s5
so if we go back to those five steps
to the workflow that currently takes us
four to five working days
now the difference is with this system
we're actually able
to take the last three steps and put
them all together
fully automated on the genexo system
so of course this will shorten the
turnaround time because in fact the
processes that are happening fully uh
automated uh are also done quicker than
if we do it manually
eventually resulting in a turnaround
time of one to two days
so in real life the instrument looks
like this this is a photo from our
test laboratory in our institute just
for comparison you have
on the left side you have the iron shift
and the ins five
and then of course in the in the in the
middle the
genexo sequencer now if we look on the
deck
of this those of you familiar with the
iron chef for example
it will look familiar to you
so basically what we have we have
different positions for different
reagents
since it really does everything from
library preparation to sequencing and
data analysis
it's a little bit more crowded than on
an i i'm chef
so basically what do we have here we
have pre-prepared
strips for library preparation um
depending on the number of samples until
and the
and the assay that we are running we
require different strips and different
number of strips
and then we have strips for chip loading
sequencing reagent polymerase and so on
also here depending on whether we run
the full chip or only part of it we
require different amounts
we have of course our assay primers
the oncoming ngs panels are
amplicon-based so we have
to provide the the primers here we have
the barcodes that
allow us to multiplex several samples in
one
run and then in the end group the
results according to
the samples of course we have a
thermocycler to perform the
the library preparation pcr pipette
tapes
and in fact most importantly of course
our input dna and rna samples
and this i just want to point out there
is one
manual pipetting step that we still have
to do and that is in fact to pipette
the dna and rna onto this 96 well plate
last but not least of course the
sequencing chip this is where the
sequencing reactions are actually taking
place and you can also see on the bottom
left on this slide
uh a photograph of one of those
chips those of you familiar with the ins
five system will see a difference here
and
this is actually we were quite happy
about this
because instead of having one large flow
cell we now have it separated into four
lanes allowing us
higher flexibility in terms of of sample
numbers
so even if we only run a few samples we
can just run one lane only and then the
second lane the next day
principal uh the reagents are stable for
up to two weeks so we have two weeks
time to finish
up the rest of the chip this allows us
to also run smaller batches
and again increase or in fact decrease
turnaround time
so after sequencing is done i mentioned
before
data analysis is part of the automated
pipeline i just want to quickly
highlight here um so once we have the
the raw data base calling is
automatically performed
and alignment to the reference genome as
well as quality filtering
and even variant calling for for
single nucleotide variants in their c
and b's as well as fusions
if we run rna as well it's all done
fully
automatic and this part of the one day
turnaround time
around time
once varying calling is done we can
get a sample summary so for every sample
that we had in the run we get the
summary view where
again we have a little overview on on
the in the top part
about our sample details
that we most of them we provided before
important here is
cellularity as you can see in the middle
in the top part tumor cellularity which
is important for accurate copy number
variation calling
but just what i want to point out is on
the right side we also have
qc metrics for every sample giving us
a quick overview on on on
coverage steps uniformity as well as on
targets
which allows us to to to see whether
whether our
our our regions of interest
in the panel are actually covered
equally
and sufficiently in the bottom part
we then have a summary view of all the
identified variants
uh again grouped by smvs index
fusions and cnvs on the right in this
case
we have a sample with two two mutations
one in b rough one in
rbb2 we had also one fusion
in the out gene present
so of course we can also go into more
detail for each of these variants in
order to
do manual quality control um
and also select in the end the variants
that we
really want to put on our report so
we were of course not the only ones who
tested this instrument now
in fact we were part of a small
consortium in europe
where we have performed an extensive
evaluation of the oncoming precision
assay running on the uh
torrent genexo system uh
the labs that participated here are
lower
were located in berlin in porto in
naples and
of course us in basel and in fact you
will hear about the results of this
multicentric evaluation in the talk
by michael hummel later today
so until then i would like to show you
also some results but some results on
very specific sample types that we are
facing in the lab and i believe that
many labs are are facing uh challenges
with
so in particular i'm talking about very
low
tumor cellularity cytological specimens
so if we look at the vast
variety of day-to-day samples that we
receive of course on the on the very
left you can see
we uh we we get resections
and those are what i would consider uh
the easy samples we have a lot of
material we can get a lot of dna rna out
of it
quality is quite okay and usually not
very challenging to perform ngs on those
where it gets more challenging is more
when we go
in the direction of biopsies actually
very small biopsies where we have very
little material and we still need to
be able to to to get the high quality
results out of an ngs
analysis and you also see here in the
middle
psychology samples cytology samples
often are
quite low cellularity meaning we have
less than 20
tumor cells and what we do in our
institutes
if we have less less than 20 percent
tumor cell content we perform laser
capture micro dissection
in order to specifically enrich tumor
cells from which we then isolate
nucleic acid and perform ngs
and these cytology samples i would like
to talk a little bit more about
and show you some some exciting results
later
so in switzerland
if we look at all the diagnosed
non-small cell lung cancers
in fact we have 40 percent of these
diagnosis that are being done on
psychology samples so they
are actually play a major part in our
day-to-day
uh activity in our laboratory and of
course
we need to adapt our ngs workflow but we
still want to be able to
to to provide useful results for those
despite having low tumor cell contents
often uh these samples also have some
advantages
over over uh formally in fixed histology
samples and that
major advantage is that cytology symbols
are not fixed informally in like
histology symbols but rather in alcohol
based fixatives and this has the
advantage that we do not have to deal
with formally induced deamination
artifacts
uh meaning we can actually potentially
call variants at the lower allelic
frequency without
without having too much noise from these
deamination artifacts
so as i mentioned many
psychological smears that we get in our
day-to-day
life in the lab often have uh
less than 20 tumor cells in fact it's
around 50 percent
as as as you can see here and in this 50
of all cytology samples we perform laser
capture micro dissection
now this basically results in as i
mentioned before in
enrichment of specific tumor cells but
as you can see on the right we
usually enrich for about two to three
hundred cells which are very few cells
uh and of course we will get very little
uh
nucleic acid material out of it and
despite this
we're usually still able to provide uh
an ngs result in most of the cases but
of course it does
it does uh result in some challenges
in data analysis also it is quite time
consuming to perform this uh
micro by section plus of course it is
expensive because we have to invest in a
in a separate infrastructure for the
example
while the samples with more than 20
tumor cell content
we basically uh we can scrape off with a
scalpel
just like from from other samples from
tissue
samples which is quick gives us a lot of
material
and is cost efficient
so we were actually
quite happy to see together with the new
uh
sequencer to also have a new assay which
is the oncoming precision assay
and just very quickly i don't want to go
into too much detail but
basically it's a it's a i would say the
mid-sized assay
covers 50 genes it covers hot spots
only and uh and uh and
covers hot spots in in in most solid
tumors
but what i would like to point out here
is actually that
this assay employs molecular
tagging or molecular barcodes which
offers enhanced sensitivity but
also specificity
so what does this mean what is this
molecular barcoding
i have an illustration here in the
bottom so basically when we start from
the left
we start with our input dna so this is
our extracted dna
um let's say we're interested in egfr
b-raf and k-ras
and of course now we have many
genomic copies of these genes present in
our input dna
so now in the course of library
preparation
instead of just amplifying these regions
we actually first tag
each of these molecules with so-called
unique molecular identifiers shown here
in the
collet in these small collet bars so
basically now what we have after this
step
is every copy of egfr present in our
input dna
is tagged with a short nucleotide
sequence that is unique for this
molecule
so basically we generate different
families
for each target gene
what we do next is we amplify these
families
so in the next step you can see that now
these families for example the blue
family now has
several family members because we
perform a pcr
so now shown here we have uh in the
in the middle on the top you see we have
the dark blue family with four members
we have the yellow family four members
we have the light blue family the two
members
so this is basically our final library
and this is what we sequence
and this these are this basically also
represents the sequencing the reads that
we get in the end
so now if we perform variant calling on
this type of library and this type of
sequencing data we can actually
distinguish quite well
a false positive artifact from a true
variant and this is shown on the very
right
you see the the uh the dark gray star
in the in the red family which is
present on only one member
so here we know this is very likely an
artifact and we would filter it out
because if it were a true
variant it would be present of course
on the original template molecule in our
input dna
and it should be present in all the
family members because all these family
members with the red
umi are copies of that
specific molecule so here we know this
is an artifact while the
the light blue star we can see they are
present in all family members
in a family and therefore it's very
likely to be a true variant
so this really enhances sensitivity and
specificity and allows us and yet to get
to a limit of detection of
around between 0.1 and 0.5 percent
allelic frequency
so if you now go back to this workflow
what we're hoping now is that with this
technology
we do not have to perform laser capture
micro dissection anymore for the load
cellularity samples but instead actually
we can now for all of the samples that
we have we can
do manual collection we can scrape off
all the cells
we get a lot of material we use the
precision assay
on the genexo sequencer to also get the
shortest turnaround time
and to get these results as quickly as
possible
so we started to test this and what i
show you here
are three different samples you see here
three
cytology smears two of which have an
estimated tumor cell content of ten
percent and one
uh at five percent
from all of these samples we had we
previously had additional smears
which we had later microdissected
uh and then sequenced so you can see in
the table below
for all three samples we had identified
different mutations so we have an egfr
l858r and egfr exo19 deletion as well as
the keras g12c
um in the in the
in in the column lcm af you can see the
allylic frequency of these
variants as they were detected when we
enrich tumor cells with laser capture
microtransaction and on the far right
the last column you can see that
all three mutations were detected
without laser capture micro dissection
when we used
the oncoming precision assay and you can
see that two of them were at
very low allelic frequencies around two
percent
uh usually for tissue we don't go below
three or five percent allelic frequency
so here we can see that we can actually
uh uh
get below that and very importantly of
course we did not detect any false
positives
in these samples at this range of
of a detection limit
last thing that i want to show you is
another experiment where we wanted to go
we wanted to test even further how
low can we go in terms of allelic
frequency in terms of limit of detection
so we took two samples again which has
been previously characterized
one are having a pic3ca hrs and pp53
mutation
and the second sample having an egfr
mutation and what we did now is we took
sample number one
and we diluted this with sample number
two in a dilution series
this you can see here in the bottom you
can see
in the first column the undiluted sample
number one
where we detect with the oncoming
precision assay
the pic3c8hs and tp53 mutation
but not of course the egfr but once we
start to dilute sample one with sample
two that has tgfr
we can see that the egf-4 starts to come
up and
at the same time the the mutations of
sample 1
start to get more and more diluted
now to make long story short if you go
all the way to the right
uh 1 to 32 dilution in fact
we're still able to detect all three
mutations of sample 1
bound to an allylic frequency of around
1
uh again even at this dilution we
detected
no uh additional artifacts or false
positives
but it will save we so we retained the
specificity
um and at the same time uh have a very
high
sensitivity so this based on these
results this is very promising of course
we're testing this
with with uh more samples now but we're
already quite happy and
hopefully in the future we can avoid
laser capture micro dissection
by employing this assay that is using uh
molecular tagging technology
so with this i would like to summarize
our experience with the
genexos system so three major points i
would like to point out
very short turnaround time
indeed we can now get from sample
to result in even less than one day so
shortest run time is 13 hours
uh longest run time if we if we if we
run the full chip at once with 16 dna
rna samples
is 30 hours but in the end
this will allow us to deliver our ngs
results hopefully together
even with our immunohistochemistry
results
second is very easy to use it requires
almost no hands-on
it requires very little bioinformatics
knowledge since the analysis pipeline is
part of
the of the automated workflow um it's an
all-in-one box so it can be easily set
up in any laboratory
and last but not least we were quite
happy with the
new precision assay employing molecular
barcoding and allowing us to hopefully
avoid
laser capture micro dissection by
offering higher sensitivity
and specificity than
other library assays
and with this i would like to thank the
team at our institute
involved in this project i would like to
thank of course also thermal fisher
for giving me the opportunity to present
our data here and of course i would like
to thank you the audience
for your attention and i will be very
happy to open
to answer questions